[Musik]
sebastian erfindet eine außergewöhnliche
hühner praline und bewegt sich dabei am
rande des legalen für die industrie
verwendet er dabei nicht nur die medien
teile funktionieren
[Musik]
jeder millimeter ist wirklich gefragt
weil nächstes teurer wie gutes protein
das eigentliche kunst stück von
sebastian lege und seinen kollegen
besteht darin so wenig wie möglich von
den hochwertigen und teuren zutaten
einzusetzen und zwar so dass es trotzdem
lecker schmeckt deshalb entscheidet er
sich das hühnerfleisch mit wasser und
anderen zutaten zu strecken
und jetzt wird geld verdient dazu
brauchen wir jetzt noch ein bisschen
salz und das eiweiß an
damit dann ordentlich wasser dran
gehalten wird mir das was überhaupt
gehalten wird brauchen wir noch einen
schönen löffel phosphat das hält die
ganzen flüssigkeiten macht es schön
knackig bei produkten mit zu viel
phosphat merkt man dass die innenseite
zähne leicht sturm wird ob
fertiggerichte oder tiefkühlpizza mit
phosphat lässt sich der wasseranteil und
damit das gewicht von fleisch um bis zu
25 prozent erhöhen und ein viertel mehr
gewicht bedeutet für die hersteller auch
mehr profit
eine füllung ist auch ein gutes mittel
um das wenige fleisch größer aussehen zu
lassen
frischkäse bildet die grundmasse und für
den besonderen geschmack mixed sebastian
läge noch etwas billige dosen ananas mit
hinein
jetzt fehlt noch der stabilisator dafür
reismehl der warme binder
dafür nehmen wir normale speisestärke
ein bisschen currypulver für geschmack
und farbe
jetzt kommen technische fragen ins spiel
die füllung darf weder im kalten noch im
warmen zustand aus dem hühnerfleisch
mantel auslaufen
man muss also nicht nur rezepte zutaten
und preise kennen sondern auch die
maschinelle herstellung
damit war in unserer hühnchen praliné
auch die füllung bekommen haben wir hier
unsere fertige maschine linke kartusche
kommt das fleisch richtig kartusche
kommt die füllung und hier unten wird
portionsweise immer wieder ab gekniffen
von hand wäre das super kompliziert aber
die maschine die hartz traum
wichtig für die industrielle
massenproduktion die konsistenz der
beiden massen muss immer gleich sein bis
das gewährleistet ist muss der
produktentwickler notfalls noch weiter
am rezept tüfteln
selbst im fabrik alltag bedeutet dass
immer wenn sich die beschaffenheit der
rohstoffe wie fleisch und frischkäse
verändert müssen produktionsprozesse
angepasst werden
1 wie das andere ist natürlich auch sehr
wichtig in der industrie dass wir
dramatisch immer gleich sind weil nur so
können wir genau kalkulieren um produkte
dementsprechend auch künstlich in den
markt zu bringen
jeder weitere verarbeitungsschritt
kostet geld
es lohnt sich nur wenn das produkt sich
dadurch teurer verkaufen lässt
läge experimentiert mit einer
effektvollen panade aus reis nudeln
jetzt müssen wir testen ob der trick mit
den reißenden überhaupt funktioniert
deswegen habe ich mir ein kleines
sträußchen nudeln gemacht wer die jetzt
ins heiße öl drucken und hoffe dass
danach kleiner blumenstrauß wird macht
viel er kostet wenig eine parade ist
immer eine gute möglichkeit geld zu
sparen
ob bei fischstäbchen schweineschnitzel
chicken nuggets oder eben sebastian
legen neukreationen dem hühnchen
jetzt kommt noch die serienproduktion
unsere kleinen hühnchen pralinés wandern
jetzt in die durch die fritteuse zwei
minuten und 30 sekunden kommen die
gefüllten hühner welchen bei 200 grad in
die durchlauf fritteuse dann zeigt sich
ob sebastian legis neuentwicklung
industriell produzierter ist das erste
kommt schon und jetzt ist das nachricht
ich wähle fließband produktion von
formfleisch münchen pralinés mit unserer
kirche mit zutaten für weniger als 30
cent stellt produktentwickler läge ein
halbes dutzend kinder welchen her billig
aber hätten sie wirklich eine chance im
supermarktregal zu landen
das hängt davon ab was der kunde bereit
ist für den knusprigen snack zu bezahlen
das produkt würde ich jetzt ein
supermarkt platzieren so sechs stück für
zwei euro 99 3 euro ein handelsüblicher
preis für eine exotisch angehauchte
hühnchen leckerei auch wenn die in
wirklichkeit dank willich panade und
phosphat gestrecktem fleisch gerade mal
zur hälfte aus huhn besteht aber nur so
geht die rechnung auf
würdet ihr bei sebastians nacke
zuzugreifen sagt es uns in den
kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mal über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonniert die zdf
besser esser und schauten die nächsten
zwei clips
[Musik]